comme un chemin de croix d'un système de
santé à l'agonie les manifestants ont
voulu marquer leur défilé d'étape
hautement symbolique
tout commence au pied des bureaux du
maire jacques pélissard et ancien député
et c'est la joie au maire qui tente de
défendre la loi ma santé 2022
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mairies préfectures agences régionales
de santé
permanence parlementaire de la
république en marche et départements à
chaque étape
la récompense a un goût amer depuis sept
mois le service des urgences de l'once
est en grève pour les manifestants
l'annoncent des 70 millions d'euros du
ministre de la santé est dérisoire
on sonne sera département avec
effectivement une zone des zones rurales
etc y compris de montagne qui sont assez
éloignées et difficiles d'accès et avec
un servait des services dégradés
d'urgence dans le département d'autant
qu'on a eu on a déshabillé
qui plus est le les urgences de
champagnole pour venir combler le
déficit sur sur lons le saunier une
situation qui mobilise aussi la société
civile
il ya une dizaine de jours une poignée
de jurassien a monté un collectif
citoyen d urgence de long on a
effectivement lancé une pétition qui a
atteint en moins de 10 jours dix mille
signatures c'est énorme pour un petit
territoire comme le nôtre on leur
remettra dans quelques jours en mains
propres au directeur de l'hôpital où
directeur de la rs on enverra à madame
la ministre de la santé
évidemment on entretiendra on organisera
tout au long de l'été des manifestations
festives d'information de
sensibilisation pour que tous les
jurassiens se sentent concernés par ce
sujet et nous rejoignent parce que ne
s'arrêtera pas et qu'on laissera pas
pour défendre le service public
hospitalier gilet jaune citoyens
syndicalistes élus d'opposition tous ont
marché d'un seul pas
[Applaudissements]